Jesse's former co-host and alleged decadel long gay lover exposed
him. >> Oh, that guy's got my exact reaction. Hold on.
This old guy right here. My >> according to Trayvon >> wrapped
around bed sheets completely around like a burrito with his head
sticking out >> and just >> that they're just playing
Nightcrawlers. Okay. Can Can a bro not play Nightcrawlers with
a bro? >> Was he handsy at his office? He was. >> Oh
boy. He kept, you know, when we took
>> he was sort of like weirdly hugging me arm around me
in a way that's like it's
>> people suck. All right. Can we do some We're going to
do some quick memes before we get into the other content for
the day. >> Jesse Lee Peterson >> JLP. Okay. This
is an old documentary, guys. It's an old documentary that got
put out by 21 Studios a couple years ago. JLP talk exposed as
male groomer and predator. >> I've changed and I and I
don't have a skeleton in my closet. >> You saying that
saint? No, >> I'm not saying that I'm a saint, but I don't
do those things. >> In the early 1990s, Reverend Jesse
Lee Peterson began his ministry as a student of Roy Masters,
a Britishborn talk radio personality and hypnotist.
Peterson and Masters promoted a similar system of meditation
and theology, a system that includes rejecting the Holy Trinity
and our blessed Lord's divinity.
>> He was also a maker. >> But thanks to the feckless
and spiritually absent bishops, Jesse's theological errors didn't
keep him from gaining tens of thousands of Catholic and patriotic
followers. Jesse's draw for conservatives was his commentary
against the Marxist group Black Lives Matter. Black Lives Matters,
um, radical, um, so-called social justice warriors.
They were chanting, "What do we want? Dead cops, when do we want
it now? Ps in the blanket, fry them like bacon." And people went
out and start cops and everything. >> Exploiting many angry
American men's desires for a stable family life, Jesse would
directly call out feminists for their role in destroying the
family as
>> Is a madeup lie. and it been made up by women who hate
men, who hate the family, who hate the unborn child.
>> I wonder I wonder if there's anything, you know, any
patterns we can find here that connects him to like the LGBT
LGBTQ community or like men for instance, like a total >> steing
hatred of women. Yeah, >> that's just that's very funny.
It just seems to be like a
>> it's just a common thing that ties these people together.
>> It's right there in your face. >> Yeah. 73-year-old
even visited the church militant studio in March.
>> Uh yeah, Dolce Bellum, this is from 2022.
We're we're just we're reviewing this cuz it's >> a lot
of people didn't know it happened or whatever. >> We're
just doing a review, man. >> When senior executive producer
Michael Boris answered his questions about
>> Did Jesus just rise from the dead in spirit or did his
body come out? Also, >> he was maybe his body counter,
but I know that's a big deal. >> He rose in the spirit.
That's what >> No, he rose in the body. >> Why I
want to make that? >> But he rose in the body. You can't
say he didn't walk out of the to walk out of the tomb on Sunday.
>> A pastor and not know that. >> he's like, "Oh,
maybe." How the [__] are you a pastor?
>> What was he saying? He was doing like his whole marketplace
like flea market thing with Eve. Like flea >> at the grocery
store. >> He came home from the grocery store to Adam.
It's like literally talking to
>> Can I get a citation on that? >> Read Genesis.
It's like what? >> And then what what did Eiday say? She's
like, I don't think that's in the Bible. Not the Bible I read.
Maybe that's in the Mormon Bible. Like why did you why don't
you know either? >> Oh Jesus. >> And from what we
knew at the time, Jesse was an ardent opponent of in and outside
the church and presented himself as >> The spirit of is
of their father, the devil. It's not them the person. It's a
spirit that made a home in them. and it came from them overreacting
to some sort of a situation in life, whether it's from someone
uh uh messing with them when they were kids or overreacting to
an angry mother because you become like what you hate. But shortly
after the March interview, friends of his came to us with a different
story. These stories first came to light when Jesse's former
co-host and alleged decadel long gay lover exposed him. 61-year-old
Patrick Rooney has known Jesse for nearly 30 years, dating back
to roughly 1992.
>> Everybody know Patrick Rooney, one of the smartest white
men on this side out of heaven. >> The two were what?
>> Cuz you become like what you hate. >> It It is
like a My >> But shortly after the March interview, friends
of his came to us with a different story. These stories first
came to light when Jesse, his former co-host and alleged decadel
long gay lover, exposed him. 61-year-old Patrick Rooney has known
Jesse for nearly 30 years, dating back to roughly 1992.
>> Everybody know Patrick Rooney. >> It's crazy how
much that is just like the Myron pictures. It's like the same.
>> same pictures. Yeah. >> One of the smartest white
men on this side of heaven. >> The two were so close that
Jesse was the minister at his wedding and the pastor at his baptism
long before Rooney claimed any activities began. Right around
that time, I also had started a TV show. I was doing a public
access TV show in LA and uh with a friend of mine who uh had
uh gotten off heroin and and wanted to he asked me to be involved
in the show to help uh other people get off drugs and things
like that. So, we started a show and one of our first guests
was Jesse and another gentleman from Bond. So, we did a couple
shows with them and from that time forward, right after the show
happened, Jesse and and I talked in the green room, you know,
backstage
and right off the bat, he started asking me stuff. Jesse's very
forward with his questioning and things like that. So, he actually
asked me right after that show, u are you gay? >> Rooney's
characterization shows that Jesse allegedly used >> curious
what how did he respond? Why did we get away? Why did we get
away before he responded? >> Similar grooming tactics as
other homo predators like Sagenov priest Father Robert Dand who
asked similar questions when praying on a young man in 2017.
>> To discover that you have some gay tendencies is a fine
thing >> because then you don't have to be so
>> Do you feel less confused?
>> Do you? >> Yeah. After Jesse discovered Rooney's
attraction, his relationship with Jesse was taken to the next
level. Bit by bit, Jesse began edging him closer and closer to
sin. >> Once we once he moved up there to do the show,
we stayed in the same house. >> Uh, very interesting choice
of words, edging, edging him along. Okay. Uhhuh. >> Jesse
would kind of do some things kind of horse play and stuff like
that with me. And at times he would uh do stuff where he would
like grab me and then we'd kind of wrestle around a little bit
and I'd feel his,
you know, >> no, don't say, "Dude, dude, don't don't say
it." >> And then we'd kind of wrestle around a little bit
and I'd feel his,
you know, private parts against me. And he did that more than
once. So it wasn't like an accidental thing. He would kind of
do, you know, what's that or whatever. And he would kind of play
around and joke about it. Fast forward to 2005 and Jesse was
ready to make his final move. >> We did a uh conference
with them called Moral Reconstruction, which is kind of ironic
now that we're sitting here talking about something something
else. It's called Moral Reconstruction. We did that. That first
conference was I believe in 2005
and we did a follow-up conference in 2006 with them as well.
And I went with Jesse to uh Washington DC uh for this conference.
Uh I was a fundraiser at the time and so we did fundraising and
I was I was part of the conference. While we were at the conference
um we stayed in uh Virginia, you know, near near DC. So uh we
were sitting on the bed together and um all of a sudden he turned
to me and just looked me looked at me and he said, "What do you
want to do? What do you want to do?" And he said it in a in a
tone that was really insistent and I'd never seen this tone from
him before. It was like kind of scary. It kind of scared me like
like what what do you want to do? I knew what he meant and then
I told him, "Okay." And at first I'm scared and I'm like, "Okay,
well, I'm playing along here." It kind of threw me off my game,
I guess, in a way. I think later I realized that's kind of something
that people do sometimes. It's it's like the devil works in a
certain way by intimidating you and it throws you off your normal
game. And so he said, "What do you want to do?" He's like, "Okay,
I'm scared." And then uh I said I told him what I want to do.
I I
X, you know, he knew about that I had already talked to him about
that I was interested in. And next thing you know, he's ripping
his clothes off and coming at me basically.
And I did the same. Took my clothes off and next thing you know,
we're we're fully at it having
not get detail here, but basically
>> amazingly full on.
>> Rooney's recollections show that Jesse mirrored Dan's
advances almost
Is this Wait, wait, wait. Is this MK's dad?
That's a crazy comparison. That is almost exact to me in my head.
I did not see that. >> That is like That is crazy. >> Not
getting detail here, but basically full on
Max. >> Rooney's recollections show that Jesse mirrored
Dance advances almost
>> I love you. Love you, too.
I know. What are we going to do? I don't know. >> No. What
are we going to do? Really? Rooney's description shows that after
this encounter, Jesse began intertwining his private
with blasphemy. >> After we had just done our this first
act, and then ever since then, he told me that once we did this,
I was born
>> It sounds >> This sounds crazy, but this is the
absolute truth. He said that I was born again. He would remind
me of that through the years. Following being born again, Rooney
contends that his sodomitic relationship with Peterson went on
for roughly 10 years until Rooney decided to come clean to his
wife and son. >> My son was really angry.
>> Oh, hold on. >> Rean Rubin donated $3. I can hear
Jesse Lee Peterson looking down and exclaiming, "Amazing >> when
he finishes." Yeah, dude. JP definitely says that when he finishes.
Why tell your son? I you know man I >> he decided to come
clean to his wife and >> My son was really angry but my
son was mostly angry at me cuz he had Jesse on such a pedestal.
He he my son had Jesse on such a pedestal he
>> that's up how how dare you dad. Wait you do you hate
me because I'm gay? No. You ruined Jesse Lee Peterson. >> You
brought him into a life of sin. >> Literally thought Jesse
could walk on water. We got on a phone call. We talked to Jesse
and as soon as we brought it up with with a with my son on the
phone call, Jesse denied it. And I said, "Jesse, you're a liar.
You're lying. You know this. You know you're lying." And he finally
came out and admitted to my son that he he he did that. >> Rooney
later moved to Florida to get away from Jesse. But according
to Rooney, Jesse couldn't handle the relationship ending, offering
him several bribes to get him back to LA. >> It's typical
for homo predators to try and cover their tracks. Is this this
is like a legitimate term we're going to use now? Homo predators.
>> We got homo predators out here. Okay. >> Using
a cornicopia of strategies to shut people up. In the case of
Father Dand, it was now deceased Sagenov Bishop Joseph Sistone
who remains silent on Dand's abuse for years while serving as
an auxiliary bishop. >> Hold on. Same predators. Homo doesn't
mean same. It means same. Same predators. It doesn't make any
sense. in Philadelphia in 1994.
>> Sense. It doesn't make sense, but predators. I don't
dude, it's >> stone allegedly watched as documents containing
names of up to 64 suspected. >> It's like narot terrorists.
It's like it was used for a purpose. I don't know. It somehow
is similar, right? It was like invented to just sound catchy
and people will know based on the context.
abusers were shredded, earning him the nickname Bishop Shredder
among the US bishops.
According to Rooney, for Jesse and those loyal to him, the strategy
was to bully and silence all victims and witnesses speaking up.
>> Jesse did throw me under the bus, basically other people
that that did anything like that and still does. If anybody comes
up with it, they'll they'll keep anybody off the air. >> You're
talking about other victims. >> Well, yeah, other victims.
uh and he'll make sure that if anybody talks about these things,
calls up his show or does anything like that, they were not going
to get through on the show. >> Patrick explained how easy
it was for Jesse to discredit victims. Given Bond's history of
seeking out troubled young >> a lot of the people that
Jesse brings around him are troubled young men, right?
Have drug problems, right? Some of them been in jail. So, it's
pretty >> Dude, is does Hake have a troubled past? There's
no way that Hey, can we get a Can we get >> Does he have
a Have you ever watched
>> Well, I realize Hey sounds like he has a brain injury,
but I'm saying does he have like has he openly talked about some
kind of troubled past? >> Feel like he is open about it,
but not that he's open about it. It's like known, right? I think
JLP like
saved his life or whatever. >> like gave him a job and
[__] like It was like literally that exact thing
that this guy's describing where it's like uh it's like the Joe
Exotic pattern as well. Okay. >> Like I'm going to find
people who are troubled, give them some drugs, going to get them
in here. All right. We're going to save them and then we're going
to sodomize them. >> Easy to discredit a guy who's been
on drugs, maybe in jail or something like that. It's pretty pretty
rotten thing to >> Beginning last November, Rooney >> gay
expose. Yes, but I can't use the word gay on Twitch. So, it's
a very very happy past, not a very very gay pass. began writing
a collection of blog posts hinting at Jesse's predation. Last
November, Rooney began writing a
>> This looked like Deepak >> of blog posts hinting
at Jesse's predation, leading him to a shocking
>> After I published these articles, I found out from a
young man, very credible young man, that Jesse was fooling around
with this young man. >> That young man was 30-year-old
Samuel Lambula, a more recent member of Bond and Jesse's latest
known purported victim. I started going to bond around May 2020.
>> Uh this was during a corona virus lockdowns everything.
As soon as they opened back, they were doing um live uh
uh no in-person church for like a two months or two weeks or
something like that. But as soon as it opened up, I went. That
was May 2020. Um the Jesse what he likes to do in the church
is he goes around first timers. He goes around first- timers
and says introduce yourself. What's your name? You know, how'd
you find us? Where are you here? Oh, just real quick. Bond here
is uh the Brotherhood organization of a new destiny. Okay. So,
it's it's his
political slash it's his mix of a political and uh I don't know,
I guess like
evangelizing
organization.
I know. >> The first thing I said, I said, "My name is
Samuel and uh I'm here because uh you know, you helped me a lot.
Uh I I wouldn't forgave my mom. I wouldn't forgive my dad. I
had a lot of anger and I just dropped that and I feel
>> got no idea if these are all the victims. They haven't
even introduced the other people yet. >> Way better now.
I I'm like I'm I'm really, you know, growing and I want to thank
you for it." >> Among him are three other alleged witnesses
and victims who also chose to tell their stories. Samuel began
his relationship with Jesse professionally, washing cars for
him and doing other cleaning work at what they call the Bond
House. The Bond House is where Jesse and several of his male
staff currently live. And when Samuel began opening up to Jesse
about his past, things got >> I was at the boy. So I was
like, Jesse, what do I do? Like this is uh weighing heavy on
me. What should I do? >> About to get Melissa's
Oh my god. Hold on. Hold on. This is Jesse. This is Jesse. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. >> This is the This is this guy.
Okay. And Jesse, leave me. What's wrong, kid? >> I just
got bullied for being gay. >> I just I I was a kid.
>> Oh yeah. What's about to happen again?
>> Oh my god. Yikes.
>> In the past, our relationship progressed slowly closer
and closer. I didn't suspect anything weird of it. There was
certain times where he began hugging me where I was like, whoa,
I never been hugged by a man. Like, what was this? But I was
like, this is I get he would just tell me like, you know, I just
love you. So, I'm like, okay, I get you, you know, I love you,
too. >> But much like with Patrick Rooney, Samuel states
things went from casually close to >> I just really love
you, bro. Mortally sinful.
So, Friday afternoon evening, I go to Jesse's. >> Yeah,
the gay music is a little weird for the gay expose. Okay, it
is. It's an odd choice. I am right there with you guys. Okay,
not my first choice for a gay expose. The the actual gay porn
music crazy. >> And I am sitting in his couch relaxing.
You know, I'm kind of avoiding the LA traffic at the peak hour.
It was a good It's a good deal. and I get to stay somewhere with
someone that I respect, friend. So then by this point, we're
already real comfortable with like hugging and and all that stuff,
you know, just hugging for long periods of time. I thought nothing
weird of it. I guess it my my guard had already been let down
completely.
So he I'm sitting in this couch, he kneels down in front of me
and then he wraps himself around his arms around my waist and
I'm like, "Okay, this is kind of weird." But I'm like, "Jesse,
why are you doing that?" He's like, "I just love you so much."
And I'm like, "Okay, I guess." I was just like this.
So then he starts rubbing my thighs and I'm like, "Okay, what
is he doing?" Like it's kind of crazy. And then he starts rubbing
my genital area and I'm like, "Uh, what's happening right now?"
And then he uh
>> Okay. What?
I've never I I can't imagine I just I straight up can't imagine
ever having that reaction to somebody grabbing my Oh, what what
what's happening right now? Oh my god, what is I'm just disoriented.
What's happening right now? >> And then he pulls down my
pants and then I'm like
I'm shocked. I'm not saying anything. I'm like my face is like
>> Oh god, he's got the freezing response. Not good. >> What
the hell is happening right now? From there, Jesse instructed
Samuel to go into his so-called meditation called the silent
prayer. >> And he's like, "Doubt all thoughts. All thoughts
are lies. Everything Satan is telling you is a lie." And I'm
like, >> "Okay." But inside is telling me, "Hey, this is
now >> from there, Jesse instructed Samuel to go into his
so-called meditation called the silent prayer." >> While
he's touching his dick. >> Yeah. Listen.
No. And while he was pulling his pants >> what the hell?
>> Okay, Jesse is touching his And then as Jesse was pulling
his pants down, he goes, "Start praying.
Start Start your prayers now. Start your meditations
>> Like, "Doubt all thoughts. All thoughts are lies. Everything
Satan is telling you is a lie." And I'm like, "Okay." But inside
is telling me, "Hey, you this is not good. Um, what are what
are you doing? What are you allowing him to do?" Samuel describes
Jesse abusing the supposed meditative state, trying to convince
Samuel to ignore the traumatic experience occurring.
It went on for a few minutes. He would uh get up, walk away.
I could hear him. I couldn't see him. Get up. He would get up,
walk away. I could hear him get up, walk away, touch it, get
up, walk away, touch it. And I was like, what the hell's going
on? So then I open my eyes and then I'm like, uh, what the what
just happened? >> Another alleged victim was tra
What? What just h guys? What? What just >> Chapman who
in 2015 told his friend now 43-year-old Arman Martikian that
Jesse
>> The first thing came out of his mouth uh that Jesse
and I say, you know, you can't be saying this, you know, like
he's all against it is a, you know, straight conservative men
who, you know, this is like what you're saying is bizarre, you
know, doesn't make sense. But at the same time, it kind of strike
me as a truth. What this guy was saying, he was explaining the
incidents like certain acts that they would do. They had some
nicknames. Jesse had nicknames for it. You know, uh
>> say instead of telling what the act is, he say named
it oral massage according to Trayvon.
>> Arman tried to tell Jesse what Trayvon
>> Oh, that guy's got my exact reaction. Hold on. This
old guy right here. My >> according to Trayvon. Arman tried
to tell Jesse what Trayvon said >> and he just dismissed
it. >> I went to Jesse. I said, "Jesse, I bumped into Trayvon
and he was talking bad things about you." The moment I said that,
his first response was, "Oh, he's on drugs."
When he said he's on drugs, shivers went down my spine like,
"Uh-oh, aren't you going to ask what he said about me?" Trayvon
has since disappeared. None of the men have any idea of his current
whereabouts, though they assume he's still somewhere in LA. After
this encounter, Arman began questioning his own relationship
with >> And then I had a flashback in the day. It was such
an insignificant thing that it never stayed in my memory. But
some reason the flashback had when I was in a private counseling.
Uh he kind of gestured me, let me see down there. Uh pointing
at my referring to my, you know, down there as in my privates,
not knowing what was about. I'm at late very late teens at that
moment, you know, like kind of got tricked into it. pull my pants
forward where he kind of look at it but at the same time I'm
thinking like maybe he's trying to see if I'm shy he's trying
to help me overcome shyness because I was a little shy you know
I didn't know what to make of it I remember saying if somebody
sees us from outside they're going to think we're gay I said
later I looked back thought that the fact that I said if somebody
sees >> it is so crazy listening to these people like um
this is like the exact thing.
Oh man, it's just I feel like people will make fun of, you know,
female victims on the internet when they say some similar things
and then it's like these old guys. It's like the exact same thing.
It's like, oh, it's very obvious when you're describing what's
happening. It's very obvious to everyone else what's going to
happen. Something different to being in that situation. I guess
>> he says they're going to think we're gay. He kind of
probably thought that uh okay, he's too aware. I'm not going
to advance any longer. Former Bond House manager, 50-year-old
Robert Santner, alleges he witnessed similarly strange behavior
in 2021
between Jesse and current Bond producer James Hake.
Oh no,
here is here is the Hake part. Okay, we're getting we're getting
to the the Hake part. I'm I don't know. I don't know if I'm going
to enjoy this. Okay, >> why are you only worried about
this one? They all been
>> I feel bad I feel bad for Hake. Okay. I feel bad for
Hake cuz Hake is like a dope guy on the internet. >> He
is the most racist bigoted
>> Okay then. You know what? I take it back. Hate deserved
it. >> Do you understand how
unapologetic
Okay.
>> You know how comically and unapologetic
um JLP is with being racist like self-hating racist?
Oh yeah, >> takes all all of those things. Okay. All
>> What I witnessed, >> so he's going to explain
what he witnessed.
Him and Jesse were hugging in hugging each other intensely.
Uh rubbing up rubbing each other's shoulder down stuff. And he
came to a point where I actually saw him kissing him on the cheek,
kissing him on the cheek and stuff on the hallway and talking
all kinds. I can't remember what the words he said, but there
were a lot of giggling. Lot of giggling in the hallway in his
James room. And then there was even one time that just really
shocked the living hell out of me is I went to the laundry room
stuff. I mean, after I checked the took the laundry out and then
when I got out and there was an door open in Jesse's room
and um there I saw Jesse was sitting in the bed and while James
Hey was >> this guy's this guy's choking up >> wrapped
around bed sheets completely around like a burrito with his head
sticking out and just >> that they're just playing Nightcrawlers.
Okay. Can Can a bro not play Nightcrawlers with a bro? What the?
You guys ain't never heard of nightcrawlers >> He was like
embracing him and hugging him and stuff and then kissing him
on the forehead
and I was like, "Uh, hey, are you are you all right?" >> Hake
to this day is an ardent defender of Jesse in his ministry, essentially
helping him ostracize all the men accusing Jesse of homo predation.
But >> Sandner also described an incident where Jesse attempted
grooming him to see if he was a
>> like there was one night, okay, I was all by myself.
It was like late at night after I came home from work. I was
in the kitchen, you know, take doing my own thing and stuff.
And then suddenly there was Jesse appeared on the doorway, leaning
against the doorway with his hand underneath his underpants and
he
>> he was like slowly massaging himself and was giving
me a look and I and I turned around
says, "What the heck are you doing?" and he was like giving me
a smile and giggle and stuff and then walked away. >> Another
witness is Martin. >> This Jesse Dude, this guy's seen
better days. Okay. Uh Jesse Jesse just creeping around in here.
Okay.
Jesse's just creeping around. Got his hand on his Okay.
I'm beating my dick. >> Francis, who's largely been leading
the charge against Jesse's purported homo predation. He describes
himself as one of Jesse's best friends. You may recognize Francis
from a video with Jesse arguing with a Univision reporter at
a >> Wait. Oh, did he get This is a scar. >> Prop
187 rally in Los Angeles in 1996.
A rally opposing the flood of illegal aliens entering the state.
>> Are you all right? >> Are you okay? Oh, I I'm
feeling better than ever. >> Are you all right? >> Yes,
I'm all right. >> Are you racist? >> Am I what? >> What
are you What are you think of these people now? Why Why you stay
here? >> Are you racist? Am I racist? >> No, I'm
not a racist. Why do you ask >> But since learning of Jesse's
dark secret, Francis has led several protests against Peterson's
outside of the Bond studio. Jesse was confronted by him several
times this year and refused to address any of the accusations
of him preying on young men at Bond. Here's a video of Francis
from March facing off with him at what appears to be the post
office across the street from the Bond studio.
>> Nobody is legal with your brother's
Oh, that's nice. He wants me to tell them how I was sleeping
with my brother's wife. That's fine. But Jesse,
why will you not speak on your
>> Francis confronted him again in the back of the building
with Arman Martikian in February, capturing it all on video.
>> Jesse Peterson, I've known you for 25 years personally.
Will you come? See, he's not coming over to me. Will you at least
stand there where you feel safe and talk to me? Stand up on your
porch with the door open and and and shout out to me.
Why won't you talk to me? I've known you for 25 years. I've accused
you of heinous things and you will not talk to me. You coward.
>> Francis admits there were also a few clues that should
have revealed Jesse was a >> This isn't It's assault. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. It's assault at first,
okay? It's grooming. It's gross. It's not it's not all assault.
Uh some of these people are describing an assault that started
things off, okay? But it's like it's like a form of grooming
to get a position of power over these people to become like their
spiritual authority and everything and then to start trying to
convince them to have with you. I think it's like clearly grooming.
It's like a little different.
long before he ever found out. >> He wanted to see if I
was willing
to have a relationship with him, of course, >> because
that's what he was all about. He was about putting out feelers
there and seeing who he could have with.
And it didn't work with me because I'd not been as a boy. And
so eventually I told him, "Look, Jesse, I'm just an angry guy
and I don't like
he's right there. He's right there." And you said, "Are you [__]
kidding me?" >> Listen, you couldn't convince me to do
gay because I wasn't as a kid. >> Absolutely no chill,
These long hugs and and all this stuff we're doing, you know,
at night. >> And did he stop? >> Uh where he would
come into my bed and just lay with me, you know? >> He
would come into your bed and just lay with you. >> Yes.
And at one time even like put his hand underneath my underwear
to go toward my genitals. Right. He never got there because I
he could see I wasn't getting excited. So, he never got there.
He just like at the edge, you know, cuz you got to invite the
vampire in is is what they say in the vampire movies. And it's
sort of true with even psychic >> So true.
>> so true. Actually, that's it. Gays and vampires, that's
the same And so he was um he would do those kind of tricks or
or uh put his hand around my back and uh up on my chest and be
hugging and all that kind of stuff just to see if maybe I could
get and asking me if uh uh how does it feel and it feels good,
right? And all that kind of stuff. And I would meekly answer,
yeah, it feels good. But uh only because
when you're under that kind of uh pressure, you just give the
answer that he wants, but you're really like wanting to get the
heck out of there. You're like ready to fly out of there like
a bat out of hell. >> Jesse appears to have used every
dirty trick in the book to silence him, allegedly trying to have
Francis arrested for violating an unserved restraining order.
>> I will go back to Phoenix and chill out with the relatives
like I was doing before, and I'll be back on the 25th. >> 25th.
I'm looking at a bit.
Yes. If it was already, you already
>> Church Militin asked every single victim and witness
if they thought Jesse would continue praying on men, and they
all had the same answer. >> Well, yeah, I would say yes,
but there's no doubt in my mind. >> There's no doubt that
there's current >> I think for sure >> Jesse allegedly
accuses these men of harassment, but some members of his own
congregation disagree, like former Bond House tenant Fabian Asencio.
>> The harassing is just an excuse for um you know, trying
to shut people down. Bond has been a nonprofit church for all
these years. He's lied and collected a lot of money from that
church, from people saying that, you know, he's been hidden.
There's a there's plenty of evidence for it. There's no reason
for us to make up anything. So, for someone to be out there in
the alley and talking and trying to wake up employees and say,
"Hey, what are you doing? Why are you still working for this
liar?"
>> that's totally within our first amendment rights. >> Jim
Valerio, longtime donor and friend of Jesse's, also pushed back
at his >> Well, we're right near the end of this. I actually
don't know. You gave me like another video here. This is Oh,
this is way longer. I see. All of the dudes from that
um documentary after it aired, they all got on like a call or
something and just started talking.
>> I haven't watched it though. >> Yeah, that that
seems like a little bit >> Too drawn out. They're probably
not organized or anything like that. >> But but there is
one last thing that ties into one of the other influencers we've
been watching recently. >> For some reason, Dpack decided
to pile on these allegations, >> but he waited until after
Pride Month. Wait until pride month had ended and then he comes
out anti-gay. Jesse Lee Peterson is gay. Was handsy with me.
What I This further cementss for me. Okay, it further cementss
for me exactly
how much gay energy Deepak puts out. I understand that he's got
like a kid. I understand he's got a long-term female partner,
but he puts out such powerful gay vibes that like Jesse Lee Peters
was just like, "Of course you're Yeah, of course. Of course you
are. Oh,
I thought Deepak was gay. That's what I'm telling you.
Like you, he he puts out such powerful gay vibes into the world
that it's
undeniable. Okay, dozens of you have asked me to address this
issue and I'm ready to address it today. I've been waiting for
the story to develop a little bit. Some of you might remember
this guy named Jesse Lee Peterson. Jesse Lee Peterson is sort
of a prominent
uh black conservative. He's a Christian pastor. He has a men's
counseling center in Los Angeles, which I've been to when I was
on Jesse's program a couple of years ago. His studio and his
radio show all go out of the same building. I believe it's called
a bond in Los Angeles. And um it turns out, it appears that the
very openly homophobic anti-gay Christian pastor Jesse Lee Peterson
is gay. And I'm going to talk about my experience with him, which
included him being pretty handsy with me. To be perfectly honest,
I wasn't harassed. I didn't feel intimidated or anything. But
at the time, >> it's always dozens with this guy. He said
it yes in yesterday's video, too. Dozens of people have asked
me to cover >> I just wrote it off, too. This this guy's
just a character. He's just handsy. Uh, but I'm going to get
back to that. Okay, so here's the story. Um, the Daily Beast
now reporting allegations of Manosphere pastors gay past royal
macho >> I don't I don't need to respond to I just don't
care about orientation. It's boring to me. it. I just don't care.
Now, Jesse Lee Peterson is definitely an odd guy. He is um seemingly
obsessed with talking, despite being a black man, talking about
how great white people are and how terrible black people are.
And he's also obsessed with talking about how terrible and sinful
and horrible it is to be gay. And he supposedly counsels young
men out of being gay, or at least that's what he claims to do.
And it seems as though he is also gay himself. Okay. Um, what
I can tell you is that the vibe at his counseling office was
really, really weird. So, let me tell you what I personally observed.
Was he handsy at his office? He was. >> Oh, boy. >> He
kept, you know, when we took P >> very handsy. >> He
was sort of like weirdly hugging me, arm around me in a way that's
like it's not it doesn't raise any red flag. I didn't think he
was coming on to me. >> I do think there are people like
this who are just like physical. They'll like put their hands
on you and you could tell it's like a part of their mannerisms.
But I do get how you could abuse that. You could have that be
the way you handle things and then also kind of like do a couple
other weird things and and sort of meld it all together into
something that's difficult to >> I didn't feel intimidated
or or whatever. There were people around, >> but it was
just like it was the first time I was meeting him and he was
a little bit handsy and I didn't really think anything of it.
Now, in this context,
maybe that was something sort of different. He was kind of like
whispering into my ear, like not sweet nothings. It was actually
about Trump. He was like, and I said this before, like, you're
you're going to vote for Trump, aren't you, David? You're going
to vote for Trump. And I quite literally thought absolutely nothing
of it. Like nothing at all like what people are describing. the
atmosphere at his office with young men kind of hanging around.
The fact that he counsels young men with Christian counseling,
I did find it all weird, but not because I thought it was a way
for him to proposition dudes because it just seemed like this
is the last guy who should be counseling young men. And of course,
he takes advantage of this entire thing where as many of you
know to say one is a therapist, you actually need a license.
You either need to be a psychologist or um a licensed social
worker, licensed independent social worker, psychiatrist, licensed
mental health counselor. He was none of these things. The term
counselor or coach can be used by anybody and he >> Okay,
so he should go into his qualifications. I just wanted to see
that Deepak was going to pile on and say he was handsy with me.
Just the term Hansy has like a connotation on its own. It was
just a weird thing to follow up with. Okay. Does he still counsel
young men? Yes, that is the whole point of his organization.
He is a predator. Absolutely. In like every sense of the word.
He almost certainly shouldn't have that organization. I don't
know if you could arrest him if nobody wants to press charges,
but like he shouldn't be doing these. >> He shouldn't be
in his position anymore. >> Put it together.
>> The boys that he counsels,
Erodite's trying to get to them. She's trying to save them. She
had to throw that >> She had to throw that interview. She
had to be very nice to them >> to get her hands on Jesse's
vulnerable boys. I'm not sure if they'll be better off, though.
it'll be >> We'll see. >> less gay.
Hope hopefully.